one girl told me come on over there's
nobody home I won't know but it was
nobody home hey everybody i'm jimmy
pardo from the award-winning podcast
never not funny
and here's a bunch of videos that I like
this first clip is the legendary 50s and
60s pop singer Paul Anka chastising his
band the audio is real somebody made
this film out of it the guys get shirts
don't they
maniac though I watched this minimum
once a week and one guy apparently was
not wearing the proper shirt the guys
get shirts that's just the way it is and
then he says and when I move I sliced
like a hammer what wait this is another
clip this is Tiger Woods at a PGA press
conference another one that I watched
about once a week watching toggle woods
hockey's way around the golf course is
made for all could viewing in recent
times but not quite as awkward as this
as a comedian we've all had bad shows
we've all had shows that a bond and Joe
stood a bomb I've never seen a bomb this
excruciating in my entire life is it
fair to say that you may have at least
lost a step or possibly a half a step no
I don't think I can still walk the same
same pace on a golf course
Tiger Woods tries to make a joke it lays
flatter than any joke in the history of
comedy
no no but seriously III can't hit the
ball as far as I used to I wanted to
represent stand ups in some way and
there's so many great stand-up Clips out
there from you know Robert Klein and
George Carlin and Brian Regan or Wendy
Liebman but I remember growing up and
watching Rodney Dangerfield I told my
wife I can relax you can cook the worst
cook in the world my house you pray
after we eat and just seeing this old
man sweating scared not knowing was a
character and just delivering these
wonderful one-liners I got hit by a car
I told the guy are you blind he said I
hit you tonight again I watched this
about once a week just to kind of lift
my spirits and laugh because there's not
a clunker in the bunch what a child that
I had my mother never breastfed me she
always had a headache our last video is
a clip from a 1979 concert of the Bands
Chicago doing their hit 25 or 6 to 4
I wanted to represent music in some way
and Chicago is my favorite band
and I picked this clip specifically
because I think it captures them where
they just look alive on stage and they
had a guitarist by the mcdonough Degas
at the time who just is a rock star so
much so that he had the nickname Pollux
[Music]
you're gonna see him climb an amplifier
here in a couple of seconds so enjoy
this
hey you guys thanks for watching I hope
that was a good time watching as I had
talking about it even though I couldn't
get that sentence out see you later
[Music]
maniac